say for instance these guys this whole
new world order stuff what percentage of
new world order do you think is
conspiracy theory what percentage in new
world order do you think it's real what
do you think
yeah
gerard would know the odds i'm
this is not something that i'm well
versed in
i've heard of it peripherally and ninety
percent of it has been from the last
person i'm going to go to is gerard i'm
not gonna go to gerard i'm actually not
gonna go to gerard okay when you think
about kai how old are you kai
84 23 going on 60. okay you're 23 years
old 23 years old when you think about
the word new world order what do you
think about
i think about overreaching of government
and the combination of technology and
the the
big social media companies okay cool so
i mean just look at what happened
yesterday could we do anything or say
anything totally get it like eric was
saying his girlfriend was freaking out
because she couldn't get a hold of her
family and paraguay because whatsapp was
down like
as much as we're relying on this and the
infrastructure and they're all
together and on the same server talk
about not being anti-fragile that we
talked about the other day too so
super vulnerable if countries unite
if governments unite and their ideas are
now i would like to be the secretary of
whatever for the european division
and the you know leader of the world is
going to be elected as this person and
if that if we go in that direction like
an eu except happens to the world minus
china and couple other places
you don't have another place to go
you do not have another place to go when
you said if [ __ ] hits the fan people in
new york can go where they can go to
florida they can go to tennessee people
in california can go where they can go
to arizona they can go to texas but what
if everything becomes the same then
where are you gonna go so that is my
only concern i want everybody to be
competing i want you to compete to read
the content to come in here so the a fan
is going to say you know adam's
commentary is weak and i want you to
read those comments and go back and say
screw you
you know johnny 69 i'm going to kick
your ass on the next podcast and i'm
going to come with some value like and
i'm like damn look at adam brought that
competition gets all of us to be like
upping up our game these guys got to get
better with the software kai's got to
get better at spelling hottie right we
all have to
figure out ways on how to improve but if
the moment the government doesn't have
to improve
go ahead say something what are you
going to do about it nothing because i
don't have to yeah i'm not going to dmv
and it's like i'm not i'm not with
real them these are the same political
officials who did not get a pay cut
while everybody else did
not one damn person said you know what
i'm not taking no pay
because my people in my
district that i'm shutting down
that i'm voting to shut down right they
didn't do this [ __ ]
and i'm pissed off at all of them
because of that because how many people
do we know small business owners that
have not recovered
you know there's people that are
homeless there's people that have like
literally no hope
that's the freaking problem
and then you have these talking heads on
on the news and this and that just
striking fear in every person
people are scared still
and like pat said you know like these
times do build up strong leaders strong
men look what they're doing right now
they don't want strong men in the media
they want weak ass dudes
they want you know what i'm saying
we should be pounding our chests man
toxic you know toxic masculinity please
call me that
screw you
you know what i'm saying
i'm a freaking american i've traveled
i've been to china i've toured china
i've been to shenzhen shenyang beijing
shanghai all that [ __ ]
and it is not the same
when i read robert spaulding's book that
[ __ ] is real
they're trying to damage america right
now
and it is a problem
and people of all races are so soft
stop and just read some freaking books
some real [ __ ]
not just the little clips and think how
manipulated
these people that we know on social
media get just by seeing like a little
snippet they're gonna see five seconds
of like let's just call it what it is
they'll say five seconds of trump or
whatever and then just go on a rant
they won't even educate themselves
and what you said about like iran and
all this other stuff americans need to
understand what that means but because
of the fact that we don't travel outside
of this country
we don't know and we're so arrogant i've
traveled over 40 countries i've been to
cuba i've been to guantanamo bay
you know i've done a lot of travel and
you know how many times i was in
istanbul turkey
and i get a call real quick i'll tell
the story i get a call from
the front desk they said mr heath you
need to leave now
excuse me yes u.s embassy is there to
take you to the airport you know what
just happened someone been lying just
been assassinated
i had to grab my [ __ ] and get on four
different flights to get my ass home
i
landed in houston
and hugged a customs agent
i hugged him
you know why
because i was scared
and i was proud to be back
we need that man people need to like
understand what being american is dude
like you don't know what it feels like
to be in another country and you have no
choice i've been to venezuela i've been
to colombia i've been in all those
places man [ __ ] is different yeah
so we need to wake the hell up like this
is like don't just like gerard says a
lot like quit just being in this la la
land and
oh everything will be fine like it will
never happen
quit using the word conspiracy because
we all saw the video when biden and
pelosi and all these other people said
oh there's no mandate there's no mandate
what they're doing now
and people voted for that
people should be pissed
they should call them out and they're
not because they got the confirmation
bias and they're just like well i don't
want to sound like you know i voted for
this no you need to raise your freaking
hand and say yeah you know i voted for a
bad policy
my bad i won't do it in i won't do it
again
that's the problem but we need to say
this [ __ ] it's okay you voted for him
good
you use your american right you voted
for it but you didn't and you had the
intention you didn't think voting for
this president that this was going to
happen i'm not saying that i don't think
any of us are but that's what's
happening and we need to wake the hell
up
i'm tired of the [ __ ]
yeah i think uh i mean that's incredible
incredible i know you've told me that
daddy's down the turkey story it's
incredible man i mean it's nuts i can't
imagine what was going through your mind
but you know i keep going back to that
old parable right like all it takes for
evil to prevail is for good men to do
nothing that's all it takes you know at
some point somebody has to be the one
somebody has to be the guardian on the
wall and like you said i mean
we're kind of in it it's a good thing
it's a good thing that all of us in this
generation wanted to be nicer to each
other that we wanted to be more
empathetic that we wanted to say you
know what i understand where you're
coming from i empathize with your pain
and i'm sorry but it went too far
and our kindness was 100
taken as a weakness they weaponized our
empathy against us now we need a little
bit of our grandfather in us now we need
a little bit of john wayne to come back
and say you know what i don't care if i
hurt your feelings i care if you listen
what i said because if you're true in
your intentions if you're true at heart
if you're not an actual racist if you're
not actually a sexist if you're not
actually an [ __ ] then you shouldn't
be afraid to say anything that you want
to say and you shouldn't be afraid about
how it's going to be manipulated
i am who i am and i'm going to be who
i'm going to be and anybody can take
what i say like you said we speak so
much and so often on here anybody can
take a three second you talked about
this on rogan anybody can take three to
five seconds manipulate it and put it
out there and then it's up to the people
all right to go back and watch for
context but i actually when i when i
talk to people when i listen to people i
think that they're doing that i think
that people don't like being lied to
people don't like being misled i think
that this era is going to be one defined
by authenticity you're not going to be
able to hide look at kamala harris look
at kamala harris she's hated and then
they went on the view and they tried
saying this because of her gender
because of her race and it's not it's
because she's as fake as you could
possibly be and you can't be fake
anymore they're going to find out who
you are they're going to know who you
are they're going to know what your
intentions are i trust the people and
that's the big difference between i
think
the the kind of you know this this
freedom movement versus this globalist
movement is i trust my neighbors
i trust them i trust my neighbors i may
not agree with you i may not like you
but i trust you i trust that i don't
need to make a law to say don't block a
fire exit because if there's a fire
you're going to get your ass out the
room i trust that you don't want to get
burnt alive i trust people i trust at
people's ability to be kind and be good
to one another and it doesn't have to be
adjudicated it doesn't have to be made a
law because when we make laws and we're
addicted to authority and we're addicted
to control what people don't understand
is what that law means if you make a law
all right you put a mask mandate out
there now the intention might be i'm
keeping people safe
well that might look good at first but
take that two steps forward what if
somebody says no
what it what happens if somebody says no
well now you have to get somebody to
come and force them out of the
establishment and if they say no to
being forced out of an establishment out
of a public place what happens a cop
comes what does it copy like what we saw
happen in australia that [ __ ] is with
that lady getting there you go strangled
at so somebody one word
is getting kidnapped being arrested is
being kidnapped at gunpoint that's what
that's what actually being arrested is
so you're having somebody you're so
afraid you're so afraid of your neighbor
at this moment that you're willing to
have an authority
send somebody to kidnap them at gunpoint
come on man so ultimately
is your point no mandates
my point is
that at this moment in time okay
that you should allow people
to live their life as they see fit
that you should allow people the the
wherewithal and the personal agency to
protect themselves and their family and
run their business and life accordingly
that's what i'm saying
that is exactly what i'm saying now if
you want to do something like new york
do something like new york fine but then
when everybody leaves
don't start taking federal money don't
start taking don't you know you know
what i'm saying like don't when when you
run out of california
and then you go to texas because
everybody
i've got a lot of special gifts in my
life yesterday i come in
gerard got me the limited edition kamala
harris bobblehead i mean there's there's
only a few of these i just want to
publicly thank you for this special gift
you got to get one that's right next to
my desk i put it right next to my desk
does it laugh
it actually does it laughs it laughs
yeah it's a new one that we have and we
have a special one that's uh uh you know
i know adam
it's it's mine i just want you to know
this i have it yeah you can we're gonna
get we're gonna get a fouchy one for you
here pretty soon so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye
[Music]